ich bewerte heute die bekanntesten
deutschen Youtuber auf einer Notenskala
von ein bis se und ich würde sagen wir
fangen direkt an mit der absoluten
Nummer
ein ja ganz klare sechs ne for real
Freunde wenn wir heute ernsthaft und
ehrlich vorgehen wollen muss ich mir
eigentlich eine eins geben weil nur ich
einzig und allein dieser Idiot für
seinen Content verantwortlich ist und
das mache ich so gut es eben nur geht
deswegen würde ich mich ganz
selbstverständig auf die eins packen bi
Beauty Palace für mich auch eine ganz
klare se
nee for real also ich meine ich habe ja
nichts gegen sie persönlich hier ist
generell überhaupt nichts wert gemeint
es geht einfach nur darum was ich mit
dem Content der Person anfangen kann und
ich habe nicht gefeiert ich würde mir
auch so ihren Content nicht geben diese
ganzen Gewinnspiel und so gab ja auch
ein paar Aktionen von ihr die ein
bisschen schwierig waren für eine se ist
aber zu krass ich ich würde in ja eine
vier so kommt auch gerade so durch
Montana black ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht mal so ganz was er macht ich
ich sehe ihn eigentlich meistens immer
nur irgendwie reagieren oder halt
streamen oder sich über irgendwas
beschweren und Skandale am haben finde
ihn privat aber sehr sehr sehr sehr nett
und freundlich und ich glaube er kann
deutlich mehr deswegen gebe ich ihm eine
drei Katja kraserwitz ach du scheiße die
brauch eigentlich
befriedigend ganz klare
sech ich meine ich kann mit ihem konte
nichts anfangen dieses ganze überkrass
sexualmäßige damals boah ne paluten ich
liebe Patrick ich kenne ihn seit 10
Jahren habe damals mit ihm in Köln oft
ein drauf gemacht und mittlerweile macht
der Typ einfach sein Ding und DAF habe
ich krassen Respekt g HD für mich auch
eine ganz klare soll jetzt nicht so
klingen dass ich so Homies mäßig auf die
eins packe oder Leute mit den ich selber
schon auf Videos gemacht habe aber g hat
die auch so einer der macht sein Ding RO
ich Verfolg sein Content ehrlich gesagt
nicht so wirklich das einzige was ich
von i mitkriege ist halt wenn er mal
wieder gegen eine Partei hetzt oder so
ein Video macht was halt krank wiral
geht deswegen würde ich jetzt ein so
eine ich weiß nicht eine zwei German
Let's Play würde ich eine dre
geben ich weiß ich kann euch jetzt auch
gerade gar nicht sagen was er hochlädt
auf jeden Fall Gaming aber das was ich
zumindest früher gesehen habe so vor
einigen Jahren war immer so sehr es war
es steckte nicht viel Arbeit irgendwie
in den Videos und da weiß nicht deswegen
würde ich ihm eine D geben julienko
meiner Ansicht
nach Macht der überhaupt
content also so ich bezieh das jetzt
gerade mal so auf Youtube da ich davon
jetzt allerdings auch keine richtige
Ahnung habe würde ich ihm eine vier
geben hier sind s wieder zusammen white
ti oh mein Gott ist das lang her für
mich for real ti damals eine ein gewesen
haben dann aber sehr viel Werbung immer
gemacht das mag ich nicht so deswegen
dann doch eher eine drei und dann eine
Mischmasch eine zwei schreibt mir in die
Kommentare ob ihr die überhaupt noch
kennt AP crime für mich eine ganz klare
eins ich mag die Jungs übertrieben also
zumindest chenges und Jan andre zu dem
hatte ich glaube ich nie direkt einen
Kontakt aber Jan und Cheng sind so liebe
Menschen und haben sich mal so viel Mühe
gegeben auch für den Content und so
deswegen für mich den ganz klare eins
Justin ich weiß nicht warum er hier hier
Drake als Trainer hat das sind glaube
ich generell die Youtube Profilbilder ja
Justin auch ein guter Freund kenne ich
auch schon sehr sehr sehr sehr lange
früher Minecraft Videos mit ihm
aufgenommen mittlerweile weiß ich gar
nicht ob er überhaupt noch irgendwas
hochlät auf Youtube und wenn überhaupt
hat er damals auch nur reactions gemacht
und dann bin ich immer nie so ein ganzer
Fan von wenn man halt gar keinen
richtigen Content selber erstellt
deswegen wür ich jtin auf die drei
packen aber wie bereits gesagt alles
hier komplett wertefrei also ihr wisst
ja ich möchte generell nieemanden
persönlich attackieren ich hoffe jetzt
dass ich jetzt auch niemand irgendwie
angegriffen fül durch meine Bewertung
hier mir geht's lediglich um den Content
den die Person bringt und ob ich da was
mal anfangen kann dena für mich ehrlich
gesagt so mein erster richtiger Youtube
Homie gewesen von ganz ganz früher von
vor 10 11 Jahren hat dann alles
irgendwann aufgehört weil er irgendwie
andere Sachen gemacht hat mit anderen
Leuten Videos gemacht hat und so fand
sein konte aber schon immer ganz cool
und hat auch immer seine eigenen Ideen
mit reingebracht das respektiere ich
sehr deswegen würde ich ihn hier auf die
zwei packen kurz gesagt für mich Clip
und klare ein ist sehr sehr krass und
vor allem dass die international so
heftig vertreten das macht ein als
deutschen richtig stolz weil das ja ein
deutscher Kanal ist apored ist für mich
vom Content her bin ich ganz ehrlich
eine
fünf ja okay mit dem bombenprank und
diesen Fake Sachen ist es schon se mit
dem insie mododus und so ich finde er
ist so ein netter Mensch und ich
verstehe nicht warum er so ein
Schwachsinn auf dieser Plattform bringt
cold mirror kommentarlos auf die ein
wenn es was besseres als eine ein G wä
cold mirror auch besser als die ein
crispy Rob für mich ehrlich gesagt vom
Content
her zwei würde ich sagen mag ihn auch
sehr sehr gern rob ist ein ganz ganz
ehrlicher und vor allem extrem
liebenswerter Mensch vom Konen her es
war im irgendwie immer so es war nur so
kochcontent und damit also ich kann mit
kochcontent nicht so viel anfangen Alexi
bexi werden viele von euch
wahrscheinlich gar nicht kennen früher
habe ich mir allerdings alle Technik
Tipps irgendwie von Alexi beexi geholt
deswegen ist es für mich vom Content her
ja auch eine zwei ich weiß nicht bisher
habe ich nichts auf der F MiGeL Pablo ja
der kommt dann auf die fün Mr wisen to
go für mich eine ganz klare ein was er
macht und wie er auf so einer Plattform
wie YouTube wo tendenziell eher jüngere
Leute unterwegs sind Wissen vermittelt
ist sehr sehr gut und er schafft immer
diesen schmalen Grad zwischen eigen
Meinung mit reinbringen aber das ganze
in ein sachlichen und gut eingeordneten
Ton und dabei aber auch nicht die
Faktenlage verdrehen also Mr wison to go
für mich eine ganz klare ein Marcel
Scorpion weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch
nicht so richtig ob er aktuell Content
bringt macht whatever ich bin halt
einfach nicht so aktiv auf Youtube ich
würde V Konen jetzt eine drei geben
Tanzverbot für mich eine fünf ich bin
ganz ehrlich Tanzi ich mag dich wir
haben uns dreimal gesehen glaube ich
bisher einmal davon war im Bootshaus da
haben wir uns ein bisschen länger
unterhalten also es waren so zwei
Minuten viel länger haben wir uns sonst
noch nie unterhalten we es immer nur so
stressig war auf irgendwelchen messen
oder so hin und her
deswegen vom menschlichen her glaube ich
ist es wirklich ein ganz ganz netter
Kerl vom Content her ist es einfach
überhaupt nicht mein Fall der irgendwie
gönnerges auf dem Parkplatz trinkt das
würde ich mir jetzt nicht anschauen dagy
weiß ich nicht ob sie überhaupt noch was
macht also von der kriege ich irgendwie
gar nichts mit ich war jetzt letztens
bei der Formel 1 in Holland bzw halt in
der Niederlande mit ihr zusammen weil
sie auch lustigerweise da war D haben
uns zufälligerweise dann gesehen ich ja
weiß nicht was sie macht ich würde ihr
auch kenttechnisch damals weiß nicht
eine drei el gella ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich habe mir noch nie so richtig ein
Video von ihm komplett angeschaut oder
die Livestreams aktiv verfolgt natürlich
kriegt man das mit mit vitaweight und so
sehr
elevate und so klar logisch allerdings
kann ich jetzt nicht besonders etwas zu
seinem Content sagen ich würde ihn auf
die zwei packen für die eins wie gesagt
kenne ich es nicht so gut aber einfach
auf die zwei weil er krank am
durchziehen ist und davor habe ich
krassen Respekt Julian BAM für mich Kent
technische ganz klare se in den Video
steckt überhaupt keine Arbeit und es ist
auch wirklich einfach nur schlecht spaß
beiseite für mich gehört Julien BAM
natürlich auf die
ein
obwohl ja direkt töten den wier
also doch auf die sechs Julia betics
keine Ahnung was sie auf Youtube
hochlädt ich beziehe das generell alles
nur auf Youtube hier jetzt gerade ich
weiß dass sie auf tiktok immer so so
lustige Videos auch macht so videosmäßig
die ich auch machen könnte das finde ich
sehr sympathisch sie ist auch ein total
nettes Mädchen ich habe zusammen mit ihr
bundespolizeiträ gehabt sind wir uns
auch so ein bisschen ja näher gekommen
hört sich jetzt dumm an also wir hatten
jetzt nicht so aber man hat sich auch
mal so ein bisschen mehr so über private
Dinge unterhalten und auch mal beim
Abendessen bisschen länger gesprochen
und so deswegen sie ich schon sehr
taffes Mädchen und un auch sehr am durch
deswegen würde ich sie auch auf die zwei
packen unsympathisch TV für mich klip
und klar auf die
eins sascha ist nicht nur der
aufrichtigste und ehrlichste und
wirklich der einzige Youtuber den ich je
getroffen habe der so eine Frage wie wie
geht's dir wirklich ernst meint und sich
ernsthaft dafür interessiert wie es Dir
geht sondern sascha ist auch mit seinem
content so einzigartig aber trotzdem
erfolgreich dass man ihn einfach auf die
ein packen muss sturmwaffel ich liebe
Freddy also so Freddy vom
persönlichkeitswert her und von der
Person an sich würde ich ihm eine ganz
klare eins geben vom Content her ist es
allerdings auch Kochen von daher für
mich eher eine drei unge für mich
ehrlich gesagt aktuell eine ganz klare
vier ich mag Simon er ist auch ein
netter Kerl ich habe schon länger nicht
mit ihm gesprochen aber früher war er
immer sehr sehr lieb aber er macht ja
irgendwie nur reactions ne blali keine
Ahnung was er mittlerweile für Content
macht ob er überhaupt noch Content macht
ich kriege nichts mehr von ih mit er ist
ja auch ausgewandert deswegen würde ich
ihn jetzt einfach mal so mittelmäßig ja
gut wenn man sich die Videos früher
anschaut dann würde ich ihm eine zwei
geben aktuell ich weiß halt nicht was er
macht ich gebe ihm jetzt eine drei
einfach so ins Mittelfeld rein stegi für
mich eine ganz klare eins weil stegi
auch so jemand ist der sein Ding macht
der ist einfach gut in dem was er macht
der macht Minecraft Videos kich ich
kenne stegi auch privat deswegen kann
ich auch sagen dass er echt ein netter
Kerl ist ich will es jetzt nicht von so
persönlichen inneren Werten abhängig
machen aber Steg ist auch so jemand der
sein Ding durchzieht und Minecraft macht
egal was ist und das finde ich einfach
sehr sympathisch Simon will habe ich in
letzter Zeit Hal gar nichts mehr von
mitbekommen ich weiß nicht ob er noch
aktiv Videos macht würde ihn jetzt
einfach mal auch eine drei geben rewii
für mich ehrlich gesagt vom Content her
früher auf jeden Fall eine zwei hätte
ich gesagt so von den Minecraft Videos
fand mal sehr lustig wie er ausgerastet
ist und so in seinen Videos mittlerweile
gerade so mit dieser ganzen Show damit
wo Leute irgendwie Mädels kennenlernen
oder Mädels dann irgendwelche Typen
kennenlernen diese dating Show das ist
ja eins zu ein von sititem kopiert das
finde ich immer nie ganz so nice
aber alles in allem hat er schon
kreative Ideen und ist auch netter Kerl
deswegen würde ich ihm so eine drei
geben im Durchschnitt grong für mich die
eins sogar
hier hier das hier bleibt die
unangefochtene Nummer ein natürlich PE
meat habe ich früher sehr sehr gern
verfolgt mittlerweile weiß ich nicht
mehr was sie machen deswegen würde ich
den ne drei geben auch so Mittelfeld
Gewitter im Kopf bin ich ganz ehrlich
finde ich vom ach jetzt haben wir hier
jetzt erweitert sich das hier oder was
weil wir hier am Ende angekommen sind ja
wir haben generell unfassbar viele
Youtuber hier noch am Start ihr seht das
ja schon hier unten die meisten davon
kenne ich allerdings nicht also alle
hier unten kenne ich nicht bzw kann die
Bilder nicht zuordnen deswegen machen
wir nur die und die habe ich auch schon
noch auf vorne gepackt die ich wirklich
kenne ich würde Gewitter im Kopf hier
bei der drei lassen also eine
befriedigend geben als note also der
anfangskonent sehr sehr gut aber dann
beruhte alles nur noch auf Tourette und
der Krankheit was ja auch gut ist darauf
aufmerksam zu machen aber es war dann so
Tourette dort Tourette dort Tourette
dort Tourette dort und davon sind sie so
wirklich weggekommen deswegen war es für
mich ziemlich schnell Zack und dann ging
es irgendwie nur noch runter trotzdem J
und zwei sehr sehr nette Jungs sehe ich
auch häufiger hier in Köln deswegen ganz
klar eine drei hand of blood für mich
ehrlich gesagt von dem Content her eine
Clip und klare 1 da werde ich ih noch
lassen das ist nämlich einfach also er
macht Gaming Content falls ih nicht
kennt und das nicht so häufig vonwegen
jetzt jeden Tag wie peruten irgendwie
fünf Videos oder so nach dem Motto
sondern wenn Videos dann lange Videos
und sehr gut durchdacht und vom Content
und Produktionsstand schon sehr sehr
sehr sehr gut hat natürlich auch ein
riesiges Team dahinter brauchst du aber
auch bei solchen Videos so oder so so
finde ich ihn so von der persönlichen
Ebene ein bisschen schwierig glaube ich
oder was heißt glaube ich also ich habe
ihn noch nie privat getroffen aber er
hat und das habe ich von viel
mitbekommen über mich immer sehr
schlecht geredet und das habe ich immer
nie so ganz verstanden ich habe das nie
so ernst von ihm direkt gesagt bekommen
ich habe ihn auch noch nie getroffen
aber hatte halt auch noch nie was mit
ihm zu tun dann finde ich immer komisch
wenn man Leute also wenn ich das dann
schon mitgeteilt bekomme trotzdem vom
konent der für mich eine ganz klare eins
Dima die Außenseiter früher auch meine
Kindheit gewesen die mal auch schon oft
getroffen für mich ich ich habe keine
Ahnung was er macht früher der konnte
eine ganz klare ein mittlerweile keine
Ahnung deswegen gebe ich ihn jetzt
einfach auch rein ins Mittelfeld ab woh
ich keine Ahnung mehr die momentan
machen ist einfach eine drei nebelniak
früher für mich eine zwei er ist schon
immer sehr sehr hart ausgerastet ich
weiß nicht ob er überhaupt noch was an
Content macht deswegen lass ihn jetzt
einfach auf der Z taddle für mich auf
jeden Fall eine Clip und klare 1 er hat
früher mit diesem Format ich weiß wie es
hieß what what the noodle oder irgendwie
so mit diesem faktenformat hat auf jeden
Fall krass polarisiert und auch die
Minecraft Videos fand ich immer sehr
sweet was er momentan macht weiß ich
nicht die Musik habe ich noch nie so
richtig gefühlt Jonas Ems für mich
eigentlich immer so eine drei gewesen
typisch so im Mittelfeld Standard
Youtube Content hat jetzt nicht krass
rausgestochen aktuell würde ich ihn
allerdings eher auf die zwei packen weil
ich finde dass er sich was die Videos
angeht auf jeden Fall sehr guten Themen
widmet und deswegen ist es für mich ein
ganz klares gut tomatoolix auf die
ein muss man kennen brauchen wir nichts
zu sagen und mit tomatolix würde ich
dann das heutige Video auch beenden
meine Damen und Herren hier sind zwar
noch ganz viele andere Youtuber ich
blende euch mal die ganzen Logos ein
vielleicht könnt ihr mit denen was
anfangen ich kenne die meisten davon
ehrlich gesagt nicht meine Apple watch
sagt mir es ist Zeit aufzustehen perfekt
von daher würde ich an der Stelle das
heutige Video jetzt auch beenden meine
Damen und Herren wenn euch das Video
gefallen hat abonniert gerne meinen
Kanal hier auf dem Smiley könnt ihr das
machen einfach drauf klicken ist
kostenlos wenn ihr ein anderes Video
sehen wollt ist es hier verlinkt da
könnt ihr auch gerne drauf klicken und
mir gerne mal unten in die Kommentare
schreiben welcher euer lieblings
Youtuber ist of all time
ciao tschus